[Musique]
incroyable incroyable
alors je vous dis cette vidéo est-ce
qu'elle vous choque ou pas parce que les
avis sont partagés mais c'est tout le
monde est plutôt choqué vous allez voir
et après vous allez voir les
explications de nos confrères de TMC
voilà qui disent que c'est normal tout
ça bon voilà ouais c'est normal il
parait que Tibet on tire la langue pour
dire bonjour
c'est honteux à fortiori venant d'un
chef spirituel comme jouer les excuses
sont bidons et le traumatisme du petit
garçon là va être terrible franchement
on dirait une scène de pédophilie donc
c'est très grave moi je ne comprends
même pas ces excuses en vrai lui retirer
son prix Nobel de la paix et il devrait
démissionner puisqu'il en a le pouvoir
pour moi il n'est plus Dalaï Lama du
tout voilà
c'est pas son nom
pas du tout c'est pas du tout s'appelle
comment Serge alors
[Rires]
ça s'appelle comment
vous êtes loin
[Rires]
il a été choisi quand il était petit
c'est comme le pape et voilà voilà
exactement il a été choisi et puis il y
a des élections pour tous les 5 ans
renouveler donc il pourrait très bien se
démettre d'ailleurs il n'est plus rien
plus personne ne l'invite rien
et moi ce qui me fait vachement peur
dans cette histoire c'est que j'ai
l'impression que c'est quelque chose là
quand je vois ça comme ça c'est quelque
chose qui fait depuis des années en
intimité comme ça et là il aurait pété
un boulon avec la vieillesse où je ne
sais pas il s'est pas rendu compte mais
qu'il était en public et filmé et il
fait le truc publiquement comme il a
l'habitude de le faire avec des petits
enfants et c'est ça qui me fait froid
dans le dos et j'aimerais qu'on vérifie
le fait qu'on se suce la langue pour se
dire bonjour
dans ce cas là c'est un truc hyper
Mexique
ou pas je vais au Mexico salut Pedro tu
vois
tu galoches tout le monde tu reviens
tactile
c'est pour ça que je veux bien tout
entendre mais dans ces cas-là c'est
ça va les gars deux minutes là l'hypotex
Mexique
c'est surtout les excuses parce que les
excuses ils disent ça sentait taquine
souvent de manière innocente et ludique
de manière innocente
là pour le coup c'est les excuses sont
encore aussi problématiques que la scène
voilà donc il y a un vrai souci Chantal
je trouve que tu as une tête à tapé
Chantal je te jure c'est vrai je te jure
c'est vrai Chantal on dirait une meuf
qui va faire de la pub pour de la
lessive j'ai pris je te jure que c'est
vrai franchement
c'est hyper choquant on sent le malaise
du gamin ça dure ça intermina et c'est
pas enfin c'est pas la première fois pas
qui fait ça mais en fait il avait eu des
propos sur les femmes il y avait quand
même créé
très sexistes très si elles sont pas
belles on les jette enfin en gros donc
vraiment c'est limite
la plupart des internautes et elle a pas
choqué les équipes de quotidien regardez
eux ils ont dit que c'était parce que
genre au Tibet ont tiré la langue
c'est la langue française
c'est bon les gars vraiment le petit il
aurait fait Dauphine
la langue de personnes non mais c'est
horrible tu arrives frère tu arrives ta
langue non mais c'est on n'est pas des
lézards
[Rires]
à présent de ses excuses un petit garçon
pour les avoir demandé de lui sucer la
langue alors effectivement il y a eu un
cri d'effroi juste avant le mot langue
au moment où j'ai dit de lui sucer la
cri des fois ensuite quand le mot langue
apparaît il y a un ouf de soulagement
ouf c'est la langue qui lui a demandé de
et pas autre chose et après le cri des
fois là faut être digéré par le cerveau
il y a un cri de dégoût de lui sucer la
langue oui sauf que la vidéo date d'il y
a deux mois mais alors pourquoi cette
polémique explose-t-elle aujourd'hui car
le dalaï-lama a réagi ce matin il s'est
excusé ce matin sur Twitter j'ajoute
qu'au Tibet
tirer la langue est aussi un geste de
politesse pour se saluer on tire
brièvement la langue c'est une marque de
politesse et de respect extrait par
exemple de 7 ans au Tibet avec Brad Pitt
é
a été signalé à l'arcome dont certains
décidez de saisir la commande je vous
dis moi moi arrêtez de saisir
comme c'est pas votre mère c'est pas à
chaque fois qu'il se passe quelque chose
dans une émission va saisir la coque non
mais sans déconner
ils vont se taper l'émission là ils vont
voir des gars qui tient que c'est bon
lâchez-les
on peut être choqué de la séquence mais
allez saisir l'arcade pour le plaisir
choquante la séquence pardon mais
imaginez que vous expliquez ça en
plateau qu'est-ce qu'il dit concrètement
il dit ah bah ça va il a sucé que la
langue bah non ça va pas désolé c'est un
enfant qui suce la langue d'un adulte
que c'est une tradition en montrant des
images je sais pas du tout ça où il se
tire la langue donc c'est n'importe quoi
les excuses elles sont complètement
bidon là encore ils parlent de câlins de
rapprochement non c'est un enfant qui
lui suce la langue et quand bien même ce
serait une tradition remettez simple en
perspective on peut pas montrer en 2023
un enfant qui suce la langue c'est quoi
comme exemple ça c'est dégueulasse et la
sécante moi je la trouve pour le coup
vraiment choquante sinon on avait fait
ça sur cette mais en vrai ouais il est
choquante mais je te le dis bah oui il
avait mis sur Twitter sur le compte
Twitter de l'émission et l'ont retiré
évidemment ils se rend compte que ça a
été un peu trop loin bah bien sûr oui
Raymond toi d'abord ce que ce qu'a fait
quotidien il cautionne donc ça me gêne
un peu de de cautionner ça après ben
pour sucer la langue moi je suis choqué
parce que je viens d'apprendre que c'est
pas son prénom
c'est vrai aussi je suis con comme un
manche à balai ça fait des semaines ça
fait des années que je l'appelle je
galère
c'est pas possible d'être aussi con il y
a 14 ans c'est comme le pape en fait
d'accord
on sait que ça
non mais vieux pané
c'est du on sait bien que c'est c'est un
prénom quel rapport
c'est pas un prénom c'est pas et la
vache qui rit n'est pas une personne
ça peut pas être un peu champ n'existe
pas
c'est dommage c'est le port salut c'est
pas un port qui fait ça
ça existe encore des champs
rouges parce que on a cité
pleines
rouges
à l'école j'en avais quand même et je
l'ai laissé pendant que je parlais
très à l'aise sinon vous avez des
bougies avec
un peu plus ludique
c'est plus smoothie
des crottes de zen et voilà tu peux
mettre dans un stylo aussi dans un stylo
en sarbac c'était super pas pour le prof
et oh on respecte pas moi je le faisais
sur des belles études
voilà tout simplement on fait des
batailles de Babybel oui allez pour
revenir au dalaïs en fait oui
effectivement on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec Elie c'est tellement
choquant qu'à un moment donné je me suis
dit mais c'est pas possible c'est une
image de
d'intelligence artificielle
manipulation parce que j'ai tellement
énorme donc oui évidemment c'est c'est
complètement déplacé c'est complètement
malsain ça met même mal à l'aise je
pense qu'il est au gâteux ou sénécence
il est il faut absolument évacuer et
sortir de là parce que vraiment il est
il y a rien qui va et après malgré tout
sur le côté on tire la langue pour se
saluer au Tibet il y a un côté un peu
nous va leur occidentale un peu
d'honneur de leçons on regarde les
autres en disant oh mon Dieu ils sont
moins bien que nous mais il y a plein de
pays dans le monde non non mais
justement on s'en fout mais il y a plein
de trucs qu'on fait dans d'autres pays
qu'on trouve nous choquant avec nos
valeurs occidentales et voilà et qu'on
devrait condamner un petit peu on dirait
que les gens ils tirent la langue
oui j'ai déjà parlé mais je peux redire
la même chose si vous voulez
en tout cas il y en a en vie tout le
monde c'est tout chocolat
il pense rencontrer l'incarnation non je
sais je sais il croit rencontrer
l'incarnation de la sagesse et là elle
se retrouve face à un vieux monsieur qui
lui demande un truc dégueulasse c'est
traumatisant l'excuse elle tient pas du
tout la route donc il attrape le visage
en plus c'est un truc vraiment
il est pas il est pas bien
il voulait juste
[Rires]